uh what do you think about as a small
tangent
um
johnny depp
amber heard trials going on it's a quick
pause it's going to resume
next week so again this is one of those
situations where you know i have very
limited information because i'm also not
sitting there watching the trial yeah
have you watched any of it little bits
of it and so
it's like i know that if i go there and
then i'm going to want to watch it all
yeah it's good i know i really it's raw
human relationships that is most toxic
at its most deep also because there's
you can tell there's love probably still
there's love which is the interesting
thing they probably still love each
other even though they hate each other
um and like there's a lot of lying going
on
it looks like it's amber heard lying to
to my
foolish eyes it seems like she's lying
nonstop but
you know
i to know the full story
and we'll never get to know it but you
see this raw
like post-mortem on a relationship on a
law affair that was clearly passionate
there was clearly something deep of a
connection there and it just
that's the sad thing about love it can
destroy you as much as it can uplift you
so they're gonna be also used to destroy
people yeah to manipulate and all that
kind of stuff yeah right so people who
um
feel that strongly
are i think particularly
vulnerable um
yeah it's
it's hard to talk about because
i've dipped into
like a podcast or something where other
people are we're discussing bad vegan in
like a pop culture way
and they're analyzing it and it's so
annoying to listen to because i'm like
oh my god that's totally wrong that's
totally wrong well if they only knew
this well i have nope that's wrong so it
you know yeah listening to other people
analyzing
um
my situation or my psychology when they
don't have all the information has been
really frustrating
the difference i did
there's a difference because the world
doesn't know much about you except for
the netflix documentary right there's a
lot more information about both johnny
depp and amber heard and the trial is
revealing the real people this is so
interesting but i haven't watched it all
okay but but there's a difference
between a documentary and like a raw
human being exactly the real trial you
can see the body language
the
it's so interesting that i think you
could tell the difference between a
person
who is full of [ __ ] and not
no i'm not sure
yeah it's another i'm gonna i can't
remember and sorry so i keep
interrupting you but on top of this
they're actors too
which is very annoying because right
exactly because like i don't know if
they're putting it but sure as hell
looks like amber hurt is putting on
um
like a soap opera act soap opera meaning
like really bad acting
and lies but i would say all of these
things are really
hard
people would say about me i don't look
like a victim
and
i don't mind you interrupting me because
andrew huberman said that's that means
you're interested in the car
you said it was a good thing
so you don't have to apologize i think
interrupt
me nobody keeps coming up but i keep
thinking of these that that's one of the
things that andrew told me that i'm like
i are you sure because it just doesn't
seem like an [ __ ] thing to do i don't
i guess it depends on the context if
we're in a business meeting and and
somebody you know talks over you to kind
of make their point heard but if it's a
one-on-one situation then it's not
i could argue anyway forever but so a
long time ago i listened to there was a
audio call um an audio that was released
of a
taped argument between johnny depp and
amber heard
um and i don't remember why
like which one of them had taped it and
if they knew it was being taped but it
was like an hour and a half and i
listened to it almost like you would
listen to a podcast where i was doing
other things was like cleaning my
apartment and i was fascinated listening
to it to a fight so i was and it's
interesting too because it's just the
audio not so you're not looking at their
body language
um which can be completely misleading
and there was another podcast where they
talked about how judges make worse
decisions
on whether or not somebody deserves you
know parole or to be released on bail
when they see the person
in person versus if they're just
looking at the information on paper
so i think body language and those kinds
of things can be can actually be
misleading
um or we think that like by looking
somebody in the eye will know if they're
lying or not but the skilled liars are
able to
um bypass that or they
because
i'm jumping all over the place but one
of the things about sociopaths is
they're not going to have the same tell
so like if i was lying somebody would
know because i'm like stressed out
mortified i'm probably doing all the
things that we do when we lie because
it's stressful for me whereas they don't
have those things so i think that
you know they could for example i think
that they could pass a lie detector test
they also don't have like a startle
response
so
the activity in their brain like if you
and i watched something
graphic and tragic on tv or watched
something happen like things would
happen in our brains that don't happen
in the brains of sociopaths so they
don't react to things in the same way
that
that we do again but that makes them
keep assuming i'm not associated i
didn't say i'm not a sociopath this
assumption you keep making it's very
interesting
then why did i murder all those people
let's get back to the um
what were we talking about johnny depp
and amber heart so though the audio that
i heard made me
without knowing anything else made me
very inclined to be
team johnny dapp
based on that based just based on that
audio yeah well that's how the people
are feeling about this whole interaction
by the way i do think it's a very
healthy thing to do in a relationship is
to record each other for months at a
time
uh every time you fight that just seems
like a very um
sarcasm i don't i don't understand how
that because they both recorded each
other
it it just it's i suppose you could look
back at all human relations and be like
this was ridiculous what was i doing
but when you're in it you don't
right i wondered that too like who made
the recording and why and
um
and did they both know about it that it
was being recorded
sometimes they did sometimes they didn't
uh all i know is just the poetry
of johnny depp's
speaking and
sort of um
movement about the whole thing it's
interesting it makes you wonder what's
real maybe this is whole
maybe maybe they're both in love and
this is like a a troll that they played
on the world i don't know
it makes me wonder what's real at all
like i
because they're you have to remember
their actors too
yeah i don't think he would have filed
the lawsuit if not i mean i'm joking no
i know but
no i mean my point is um yes yeah
if somebody was trying to make the
argument that like he's the abuser
and that he's lying and he's full of
[ __ ] it sort of doesn't make sense that
he would have
filed a lawsuit unless he's trying to
have this all
come out in the open
because he believes he's in the right
you know again i don't i have no idea i
agree with you i agree with you
as a fan of
love and human nature i appreciate the
fact that they went through this i know
it's probably extremely painful
but
it's it's fascinating to watch human
relationships be presented in such a raw
way and it made me realize how rare it
is to get a glimpse like that
you